Unknown: Welcome to pod two fifty six. Oh, it says we are live streaming. What a way to introduce I you don't know if we're actually live streaming. I'll double check. But anyways, welcome episode one one seven. Today is June 17. And we've got Scott and Tyler back in the studio today. Welcome, gentlemen. Yo. Yo. Thank you. It's good to be back. You have been going to some pretty cool places
and seeing some pretty cool things.
Last week, Scott, while you were traveling, Tyler and I had
agent p who is working on grid pool on the show, and he gave us an awesome rundown
of everything he's building with that. But I would be thrilled to hear
about the Oslo Freedom Forum and about Prague
and anything else you guys wanna share about where you've been and what's been going on. Yeah, sure. I mean, I'm
Unknown: jealous that I missed the
talk with Agent P. All my discussions in the past with him have been amazing. He is just one of those, you can just do things kind of guys. It's like you like to see it. That's for sure. Yeah, dude, he was awesome.
Unknown: Just very
clear minded,
very practical approach. I
just love to see what he's doing and he's just doing it all in his spare time and leveraging AI to help him do more with the limited time that he's got. And I think it's working out great. Yeah, we wish you were here, Scott, too, because sometimes at some points in that conversation, Eco and I were like deer in headlights trying to understand it. Well, feel the same way talking to him. He's just like
Unknown: going a million miles an hour. It's pretty cool though. Have to go back and listen to it. I haven't had a chance yet, but sounds like it was a good one. I think he just did
Unknown: a forum post. Yeah. He did. He updated
grid pool. And I think maybe I'd like to think after our conversation,
it highlighted to him, it might help to have some, like, descriptors on the website. So if you go to, what is it, gridpool is it .org? I think it's .net. .Net.
Thank you. Yeah. If you go to gridpool. Yeah. He's kinda like redesigned the website a little bit here. Mhmm.
And got some Big overhaul. Yeah. He's got some explainers on there to break it down for Luddites like Tyler and I. Yeah. This is cool. Cool for cypherpunks.
Unknown: That's how we need it. I love it.
Oh, yeah. This is looking way better than last time I looked. This is cool. How it works. That's neat. That's neat. Okay. I'm definitely gonna have to dig into this. Indeed. This is cool. Right? This is what we need.
We've we've heard Mechanic and other people say that, you know, we can't have a million different pools. Right? There's just not enough blocks for that to work. And he's right. We can't have a million different pools, but that I think what we do need is different pools. Right? So I don't wanna see that like a million can't survive, but we definitely need new ones. So we need people working on this, coming up with new ways to to rethink how a decentralized mining pool works.
Because there there's certainly work to be done here. And, you know, not all of them can work, but, some of them can work. And I think that'll be for the best in the long run because the way we have it now is
I don't know. It's kinda just like old, and we've seen how it tends to to trend towards centralization,
Unknown: which is not good. I mean, considering that there's only like 15 pools listed
on that pie chart on mem tool, mempool.
Space, we've got a long way to go to a million.
Unknown: Yeah.
Unknown: So there's definitely some room for some competition here. Well, and the pool, I mean, in its current state, the definition of a pool, like, means the status quo is essentially run authority. But Right. When Bitcoin came out, I mean, mining pools didn't really exist.
They didn't exist. And so
I think we've come to be complacent with the status quo and say, well, this is just what a pool is. Some company runs it. Yeah. They can take their dev fee and, yeah, they do different payout structures. Some are better than others. Really, I mean, that brings us back to GridPool and p two p two.
Nothing's stopping us from just redefining pool to be a protocol solution, not a company solution, not a company offering. Yeah. Lots
Unknown: of complacency over the years has gotten us into a sticky situation here. Yeah.
Unknown: Yeah, I think that's right. It's kind of shortsighted. It's like, well, we've got a central bank,
how could we do money differently? It's some of the same thinking that went into the ideas that spawned Bitcoin that I think need to go into Bitcoin mining. Yeah, definitely. Super awesome to see. Yeah, definitely recommend checking it out if you haven't heard last week's episode with Agent P.
Gridpool.net.
Unknown: Yeah. Gridpool.net.
Scott, what was your takeaway from Oslo? We were both there together. We got to talk with some wicked smart people, smarter than us. That was a crazy BitDevs, by the way, with all the gigabrains in the room.
Unknown: That was a crazy BitDevs. I was like, wow. I guess bit devs are always kind of like that, but yeah, that one was very well attended. I think there's a lot of people in town.
It was just, yeah, the topics were very technical and went deep. It was cool to see. I mean, it had core developers in the room and lots of people that I had just met for the first time on that trip who were like, you when you just meet them at the bar or whatever, like, Oh, hey, what are working on? They're like, Oh, you know, I'm working on this and that. And then at BitDevs, it's like, Yes, I'm a core developer working on this essential part of Bitcoin, so it was cool to see that at BitDevs. It was. But what was also shocking to me was even the core devs I mean, everybody's got their little lane, right? Their passion project, what they're focused on. We're hyper focused here at the two fifty six Foundation. And I'm guilty of this as well.
Unknown: I definitely don't know all the nuances of all the internal debates happening with Bitcoin Core, for example, but it seemed like no one really knows how centralized mining hardware and firmware and the actual supply chain and these monopolies involved. How crazy that stack up is, the current status quo of mining. So I think that message was interesting to to convey to those people in the room because they really were like, oh, I didn't think of it that way. Yeah.
Unknown: Yeah. That is interesting. I'm always floored when I talk with, you know, an extremely
technical,
like, longtime Bitcoin developer,
and they're like, we tell them that stat about how Bitmain,
you know, controls
80% of the hardware market, and they're just like, wait. What? Like, just no idea whatsoever.
I think a lot of that comes from this traditional divide that has been between sort of miners, Bitcoin miners, and then the rest of the Bitcoin developer world.
Like, they they just there's those miners over there doing their thing. Like, that's not our business. And then we're here working on Bitcoin and and vice versa. It is it is kinda starting to break down, though. Like, the the two sides are starting to talk,
Unknown: which I think is at least in a small part from what we're trying to do here. So we gotta keep on keeping on. What you're describing there is like exactly what I noticed when I when I first started learning about Bitcoin, it was like, you know, learning about hardware wallets, learning about software wallets,
learning about running a node, spinning up a lightning node and like running lightning. But like mining was this just like area in the corner of the room that was just darkened
And no one was really talking
about it or innovating in that space or
really getting into the weeds and explaining how it worked in
Unknown: very clear, accessible terms like the rest of the areas that I had been learning about. And do you think that happened? Because like I said, nodes used to be miners. It was all one in the same. Is this around when the ASIC came out? Is it before that? This bifurcation in
node protocol and then the stratum protocol for mining communication. Then beyond stratum, they say, Okay, it's not my problem anymore. I just have to deal with sending this information to the miners and receiving this information back from the miners. Dude, it's a good question and I don't
Unknown: because I didn't start getting into Bitcoin until the end of twenty eighteen.
And it was definitely like mining was just this
thing that happened in the background
and not something that was really accessible.
At least, I
was consuming most of my educational content about Bitcoin from Twitter. So there is that too. There's plenty of other places people can go and discussion forums people can have. And maybe mining was a very hot topic in other places, and I just didn't really see it where I was when I was there. But just speaking
from my point of view,
just really seemed like mining was just this thing that happened, no one really talked about it. And
it
took a long time to really start making it more accessible for people.
Unknown: What's funny is like,
Scott, we learned that a lot of the protocol devs, the core devs are so focused on protocol that they don't really think about mining. And then you go talk to mega miners and they're so focused on fiat and energy, they also don't think about mining.
There's no one that thinks about mining development.
Unknown: It's a small group. Yeah, we're a really niche part of Bitcoin here. Mean, was my main takeaway from the Texas Energy and Mining Summit, which was amazing. But all the talks from the large miners were like, they're so focused on the very big job of securing power purchase agreements, building infrastructure,
getting the permits, and building out everything that it's almost like, all right, yeah, we got the building, we got the power, we got the permits,
we're done. Just throw some boxes in there and plug them in. Yeah, give me the shoe boxes.
Like that's They're like, okay, whatever. That almost seems like an afterthought is the actual miners,
which seems strange to me. But, you know, we've seen lots of the miners that just they don't really have much in the way of like well, they don't have any mining development staff on hand. You know what I mean? Like, they they can, you know, engineer
a zillion rad ways to do a dry cooler and set up everything and deal with all of that in the community and in all the fiat stuff, like running a publicly traded company and dealing with boards and stuff like that. But as far as actually
knowing what's going on with the mining machines, which generate all their revenue, they're just like, now we just plug it in. Yeah, it's crazy. And I think this all highlights how difficult it's been for the two fifty six Foundation to communicate
Unknown: what we're doing. And it it's helped me understand
Unknown: why it it seems like our message gets lost across a number of people that I talked to that just don't really quite understand what we're doing. Well, how did it become clear to you, Liko? You know? Cause we all agree now we've arrived at this conclusion that we need to build these open source building blocks for the mining stack. They don't exist in its current form.
Was it pain points for you when you were trying to get into home mining? I know you've talked about that extensively before. Was it immediately clear? Did you kinda come to this conclusion over time? Like, oh my gosh, I can't modify this, or how does this actually work? No. It it was not immediately clear.
Unknown: I mean, just like getting my hands on a miner and plugging
it in and opening the interface
and configuring
the pool and the worker name in there and connecting to a pool. I mean, that was all just like a big learning curve for me when I first started getting into it. So like understanding
the limitations of using and risks, I would say of using closed source hardware and firmware, that didn't happen until much, much later. I think it was several things. It was trying to scale up and grow beyond just mining in a residential basement, and actually
trying to evolve into
a shipping container and actually make a legitimate operation out of it. There was a lot of failure there. And it wasn't
all because the hardware was closed source.
Most of it had to do with bad timing and not understanding
exactly what the
contracts with the electrical company meant and implied. That was my biggest mistake. And also not being well capitalized and not being able to survive through the rough patches.
Scaling up is really hard and there's like, it's death by a thousand cuts. But I think just trying to continue
to do something with mining that was tangible for me, having tried to scale up and failed, but still wanting to do something. Just, I think in that time period,
which took several months, if not a couple years,
it kind of dawned on me that there's
the
one business model I tried, which is like a shipping container full of miners. Okay, that failed, that didn't work. But surely there's other
opportunities
to use mining to be an entrepreneur.
And so there's heat reuse applications.
And I think in thinking through some of these other use cases,
that's when it started to become apparent to me that it's really difficult to just take this closed source hardware and make it do something
that it wasn't designed to do necessarily
in a unique application that supports another business model other than just filling racks with miners. And that's, I think going through that process is where I really kind of honed in on like, hey, wait a second,
is bullshit. The whole ecosystem is supposed to be open source. This is Bitcoin. Why is this part closed source? And
then I think just once you see it, you can't unsee it. And then
it's just this like festering problem that you just refuse to it. Filipe, correct me if I'm wrong here, but when
Unknown: you got started, Iko, with your
mining adventure here, it was still of the era in which if you could figure out a way to plug in machines, you would be profitable. Yeah, mostly. And I touched on timing a little bit. So when I tried scaling up, it was
Unknown: the summer of twenty twenty one, which was the great Chinese mining ban, where half the hash rate went offline. And
so that's when I really made my first big leap trying to go beyond
being just a home miner. And I think I recognized that there was an opportunity there, but what I got wrong was buying
miners before I had a place to plug them into. And so what ended up happening, I've still got
What's Miner M30S
plus miners that are brand new in the box, never even been opened. They're just sitting in a storage unit, not doing anything. And that's a result of recognizing
there is an opportunity,
having the ambition to try and go after it, having enough resources to try and go after it, but just getting the timing wrong. And I think that's where I really screwed up. And, you know, just not having the outlets available to plug those miners into is really what screwed me over. Actually, as an aside, I think I might wanna buy one of those off you.
Unknown: We've got some work to do in reverse engineering what's minor, and that might be a nice place to start. Yeah. I've I've got plenty of Okay. So So I I was thinking like
alright. So we're in this era which, you know, if you can plug in miners, if you can get the miners, if you can get the infrastructure necessary to actually turn them on, you can make money. And I feel like that gold rush is done.
People have taken it to the extremes. These pubcos have figured out how to raise boatloads of money to build the infrastructure to plug in a lot of miners. And, like, many such companies have done this. And it just really seems like that era of just plugging them into the grid, using them exactly, you know, as they're intended, the machines exactly as they're intended is just, like done. Like too many people have done it. And it seems like we're getting into this era where, you know, you touched on it,
we kinda you need to get creative in one way or another, like getting your your, power for cheaper. Right? Like, figuring out how to go after stranded energy, intermittent power. Like, you know, you gotta be more creative. And I think that's where we can start to provide a lot of value is, you know, either using the stock machines in a
different way than they were intended or actually just building new machines to use them differently than they were intended. Yeah. Exactly. That's that's a 100%
Unknown: spot on.
Because I think framing it like a gold rush is is very accurate. And I remember, you know, thinking
that to myself that during that time that like, this was like the modern day gold rush and, you know, having been out of it for a couple or, you know, past that time now for a couple years and looking back, it definitely
it definitely has a lot of similarities to a gold rush. And I
think that era of just plugging in miners to like, and filling racks in a big warehouse, I don't think that's sustainable. And I've been saying that for a while,
but to bolster your point, yeah, you do have to get creative.
And I still think that there's a lot of opportunity there if you can figure out something creative enough, either with alternative power sources or really cheap power sources, or just like miners that have been
totally reinvented and they're not necessarily
Unknown: your your standard shoebox miner anymore because they're being used in a way to support another business model. Well, you know, it's an exciting time, I think, be doing what we're doing. Know I realize a lot of people are either getting out of Bitcoin mining, you know, or signaling that they're going get out of Bitcoin mining for other things. But Bitcoin
mining certainly isn't going away.
Unknown: Right. Well, and to just round this out,
order to achieve any of those creative solutions,
you can't do it on closed source hardware or firmware. You
have to start using open source hardware and firmware, which is why I think what the two fifty six Foundation is so important. Was that message well received in
Unknown: Prague, Scott? I wanna hear how that went. I saw you had a panel with Wonklue. Yeah. Yeah. I I did a we did a panel on home mining with,
Unknown: with myself and Wonklue and Nacho
and a guy from Brains.
That was that was actually a really good conversation talking about home mining on the main stage. It was moderated by, what's this guy? The guy from The Netherlands. He was he he aped into the bid acts early.
And yeah, that that was a good conversation talking about, you know, how you can just do it, how you can get started, like getting people into the the industry more or less, right, through home mining and, you know, getting them realize
that they can just do it. And then then, you know, some subset of those people will go down the rabbit hole,
and get more and more into mining, whether they become mining developers
or just working to grow their grow their hash rate and looking at different interesting ways to do it. So that was a cool panel. We also did Lars and I did a, the next day,
did a fireside chat just between us that was really cool. We talked about kind of the origins of the Bidax and OSMU
and why we decided to do it open source and how, you know, critical that was toward getting the the movement going.
I mean, I think it was, you know, kind of a ridiculous thing to do initially.
I know that even myself, was like, is anyone gonna want these small miners? Like, what's what's the point?
It's also a very big task, very hard to do. There wasn't a lot to look to. So going open source was really essential towards, you know, rounding up the handful of people that were interested in doing this and and creating something that worked that people could then jump in and start developing on or just running. That was a really fun chat. It was interesting, though. Right before
that fireside chat was a presentation by a guy named Jan, not the original Jan, but another dude named Jan at Brains,
in which he announced that they are going that they have forked off they have forked their Brains has forked their hardware business into a separate entity called BrainsForge.
And, you know, they at least claim they are very dedicated to open source. They're gonna open source some of their hardware designs. They're gonna open source the firmware. They're making a firmware that's compatible with Bitaxes.
Unknown: Woah. Wow.
Unknown: Interesting. Yeah. It was really cool. I mean, I I actually didn't get to hear the talk very well because I was, like, back stage getting ready to go on our talk. But I went over to their booth afterwards and talked to them quite bit.
It was exciting because brains used to be open source, right? They were the first ones to create a third party firmware and it was open source when they created it. I think they generated a lot of goodwill in the industry, but perhaps they were just a little bit early. And then they kind of just, in my opinion, rugged, rugged the community by going closed source. And it sounds like there were some people at the at the organization who weren't happy with that and really wanted to do something. And so, you know, in no small part because of the Bidax project and two fifty six Foundation, they've decided to to jump back into open source, and they've made some very interesting products
and projects.
They haven't actually released anything open source yet. So it's, I guess actually releasing is TBD, but they claim that's what they're going to do. So that was really interesting to see. Think, you know, I think we're making a difference, right? People are seeing this and there are some folks out there demanding open source, which is good. Yeah. I hope to see that sooner than later. And I I think they will. I'd I'd like to think that the guys at Brains are well aligned with the ethos behind open source, you know, just cause that's how they started with their firmware project.
Unknown: They've been very quick to get involved with the two fifty six Foundation at at pivotal pivotal
moments for us. Like, for example, they they did open source some of their control board hardware
design. Not
the firmware for the control board yet, but they you remember when we did the first Telehash,
they were quick to come alongside us and announce that they
were gonna open source that too,
which they did.
I don't think their marketplace really
has anything to do with open source, their Hashrate marketplace, but
during another one of our telehashes,
they announced that in conjunction with us doing the telehash. So yeah, I think they've got their eye on us and, you know, there's a reason for that because they like the idea of open source. So I'm glad to see that they're continuing to think of new ways to to participate and support it. Yeah. Yeah. That's what we like to see. I mean, showing that
Unknown: that there's a demand for this and,
you know, I hope that, they can be profitable doing it. Right? I mean, that's what we like to see is profitable businesses on top of open source, you know, reaping the benefits
of of a robust community and creating features and moving this whole thing forward. And, you know, even though in this case, it the the it comes from
a centralized entity just by the fact that it's open source that does significantly
decentralize
it. Right? Once the source code's out there, then it's out there. And,
you know, if brain you can't really take that away. I mean, even when brains closed source their brains OS initially early on, like, the original firmware for it was still out there. Right? You can't Right. You can't take that back.
This
is a win for decentralization.
Unknown: They're also a good example of, with Forge specifically,
dabbling in hardware, the Brains mini miner too, that miner with their control board inside and I think it's got S19 chips and the little touchscreen on the front. It's a good example of showcasing that
miners don't have to be made by the ASIC manufacturers.
Right? Like, that's a product they developed and sold. It's not a retrofit. Right? It's not an s 19 with two hash boards ripped out in a three d printed case, which is also great, the retrofits.
It just shows that, like, they're scaling this as a business and open source should make that easier. I saw they chimed in on Adi's tweets about
Unknown: getting doom on the brains mini miner screen, and they were all about it. So for them, it unlocks more features, more community development, easier product development. If someone already figured out how to communicate with those chips or Mugena already worked for the features they wanted, then they wouldn't have to go re engineer it. So yeah, it's cool. I'm excited to see what comes out of BrainsForge in the coming months and years. They they announced a new Brains mini miner. It kinda has a different form factor. It looks very nice. It uses the BM thirteen seventy chips. Those are the same ones that the Bitaxe Gamma uses from the Antminer s 21 pro. And I was I was talking with them, and I assume, you know, because they've been in this for so long that they would have some, you know, like, way to get new chips,
to get new Bitmain chips. And they're like, nope. We're just unsoldering them just like you. I was like, wow. My gosh. No way.
Was very surprised to hear that. They're mass producing stuff. Yeah, mass producing stuff with unsoldered chips. I think people have really streamlined that process, like almost automated to a way. They're like taking the chips off, testing them. They actually replate the chips so they look new. Yeah, it's both amazing and ridiculous to see. Like, this is not how it should be. But there's gotta be an ASIC manufacturer
Unknown: out there that sees
the opportunity to just sell the chips.
Unknown: Yeah. Yeah. And I think they are, right? We've had exciting initial conversations with some non Bitmain ASIC manufacturers,
and they're
picking up the phone for the first time ever, which is exciting.
I wouldn't say that they fully get it, but
Unknown: we're on the we're on the radar now. Yeah. A year ago, they weren't picking up the phone.
Unknown: Not really. Not really. I mean, we were just getting some initial, like, pings. I was but it it was Was like there? What's that? I feel like Proto was there. Yeah. I mean, I had some pretty early on conversations, like, well over a year ago with Ardine
and Proto.
And I mean, Proto is different. Right? Block, I think they fully get it. But, you know, some of the others, like, from more traditional,
essentially not Bitcoiners,
they, I think they initially see like, oh, like, you know, there's there's some people making some money out here. Like, can we make some money? And then it takes a little bit of of of discussion to be like, this is an open source project,
which I think breaks a lot of brains because normally they're like, okay, cool. Like, how many, like, thousand reels do you wanna buy? And you're like, me? None.
Unknown: Yeah.
Unknown: That's a good point. But it's happening. It's happening. We've had some very encouraging discussions. And of course, Block and then now with their their mining,
division Proto,
like, they've been in from the beginning. I think they totally get us. They've, like, pledged their support to towards, you know, having a Bidax, towards getting us access to chips,
towards, you know, funding and supporting Bitcoin Park, two fifty six Foundation, things like that. So they definitely get it. It's
making an ASIC chip is also insanely hard and takes a very long time. It's very resource capital intensive.
So but it it's coming along. Yeah.
Unknown: Yeah. I hope more of them keep picking up the phone.
I mean, we've got CanAnn out there who has been
recently
more involved.
I know you guys did some chats with them that
were recorded and they they posted on social media. If there's anything there you wanna touch on. Yeah. I was actually just scrolling on the 256Foundation
Unknown: X account and I saw Canaan. I mean, they've they've posted quite a bit since Vegas,
Scott, about
their interest in open source, which is kind of a funny way to do it to your point earlier, how they're just
tiptoeing around it,
and doing that publicly in a way that's like, should we open source stuff? Some of their tweets are literally just, like, asking, and I think that's interesting.
But also, there's a cultural barrier, one. But, yeah, it's it's a step in the right direction. Right? I'll just say that. Yeah. It's it's several steps in the right direction. I definitely appreciate But,
Unknown: yeah, we are we are dealing with some very I have just proprietary mindset
people at these companies, but hopefully, can change some minds. Most certainly. Yeah. We gotta talk to NG. NG at Canin, we'd love to have you on the pod. He just did an episode with Stephane Lovera that came out today. Oh my gosh. Really? Yeah. This is the NG that, like, created the first Avalon chip. Right? Oh, yeah. Yeah. I mean, I think Leo at Canon,
you know, at least what he said was that, like, NG, like, wanted to open source this initially on Yeah. That's right. I'm taking a note. We should reach out to him. If how things would have been different had that gone through.
I'm sure that was a difficult ask, right? Especially when you're first making ASICs, right? You're like, this is so expensive. We don't even know like what this market is like. We're just shelling out money. Is this even gonna be a thing? Yeah. I'm sure that was daunting for sure. But now they're not even the big dog at the table, you know? Now they're they also have to deal with their competitor, Bitmain. Right? Yeah. Bitmain has just been a juggernaut. It's kind of swallowed up everything. I mean, massive market share. Like, their a six are significantly more performant and cheaper than, like, everyone else's by a wide margin. I did go up to the Bitmain booth in in Prague, and Nice. Like, the first guy that came up to me, I was like, alright. When is the s 23 air cooled shipping? And he just looked at me and he said, never. Never? Woah. That's what he said. Never. So they canceled the product? Again. This is the second time I think they've canceled it. Jeez. So that was interesting. But they did have lots of, s 23 hydros on display there.
Any immersion miners? No. I well, I didn't see any. Immersion is dead. Yeah. Immersion is dumb. No one wants to do that. I don't think anyone liked it. I mean, maybe like the idea of it. Once they actually did it, they're like, this is just a mess. Yep. Interesting. So they're leaning into more mature server style
three phase, never gonna run-in your home miners. Let's just Never say gonna run-in your home. Yes. Exactly. Yes. I mean, they they like they have that rack mount s 23 that like has that long part number that I don't even remember. But like, I think the thing's like $23,000
Like, that's a beast. And then they have that that smaller sort of more standard well, not standard, more typical
form factor hydro miner. I think it's like 15 or $16,000,
Unknown: something like that. But I mean, if if these aren't going into like if the business model for massive warehouses and racks of miners is dead, and the new business model
I mean, who are they trying to target? Is it like companies that have established
power purchase agreements and they have to consume a certain amount of power and they're selling most of that to AI compute,
but then when are are they just buying Bitcoin miners as like like a a fallback for when the AI compute demand drops, but they still need to consume power and they can just spin up miners. Is that the play that's I have the same question. Like, who are they they're making these pretty polished 25,000
Unknown: rack mount hydro miners and all the not a lot of those mining operations with those kind of budgets are shutting down and switching to AI. So who are they selling Exactly.
Unknown: That's what I I know that the the way that Bitmain has done business for a really long time is through this weird, like, coupon market. Right? Like, if you if you buy miners
and they break, like, instead of refunding you, they give you these coupons, which are just, like, Bitmain credits. Right? So I gotta believe there's a lot of Bitmain coupons out there. Like, no one pays full retail? Yeah. So I don't know if it's like this sunk cost of like, all right, well, got all these
coupons, right? We get all this discount on Bitmain gear. Like, I guess we should get those.
Unknown: Jeez. Yeah. Just doesn't seem sustainable to me. I don't know. What do I know? I've I've failed trying to scale up, so I don't know. Maybe there's maybe there's something I'm missing here. Yeah. I mean, I'm sure people will buy them. Did you have any other conversations? Any more detail with the Bitmain team or no? No. That's all I got out of Just that one word, no? Yeah, basically. I asked if I could open up That's one of the S23 hydro units and he said
Unknown: par for the course. Yeah, I kind of expected that.
There's a lot of excitement for the new S23 chips, which are rumored to be called the BM thirteen seventy three. And there's some there's some folks creating, like, BidX style miners
with them. But as far as I know, no one has really got their hands on one of these miners. So it's really hard to to know, like, how the chips work. Right? It's hard to inspect them in the miners. We don't even know if that's what's in them is the BM thirteen seventy three, without getting a look. And it is a little weird too because you can on these these Bitmain chips, there's always been a register that you can read, and it tells you the model number of the chip. Mhmm. So, like, if you're on a BM thirteen seventy, you read this register, it comes back BM thirteen seventy. If you if you read that register on the BM thirteen seventy three, it comes back BM thirteen seventy two, which is really odd. So I don't know. And I think the there's not that many BM thirteen seventy threes out there, and the ones that are,
like, I don't know, rumors that they're, like, stolen, but, like, it's really unclear where these come from because the machines aren't shipping. So you can't be on soldering the chips. Like, it's too new for the repair markets to have replacement chips available. It's Weird. What the hell is going on there? You because, like, they just fall off a Bitmain trucks and I think so. I think so. I mean, a friend sent me a a b m thirteen forty chip, which is is the same size as the b m thirteen seventy two and three. It seems like it was a precursor to the b m thirteen seventy three.
But he sent me the chips and a photo of the hash board, and it looked like it literally fell off a truck. Like, the corners all busted off and like, I don't even wanna know where this came from. Dude, crazy. But it doesn't have to be this way. We've seen this a lot, even with the BM $13.70 chips, you know, there'll be a couple of reels that come on the market and people get and then it just disappears. Right? It's like,
I think that I actually my theory is that these chips are disqualified
by Bitmain for whatever reason and they just find their way into the gray market. Interesting.
Yeah. That would make sense. It's like they throw them in the trash and then someone's like, Nope. Just got them out of trash. Oh, I can sell these on AliExpress. Right. I'm curious to see what products they come out with. Yeah. Well, and you've made this point in the past, Scott, where it's like these underdogs
Unknown: like Can Am, there's no downside to them going and supporting open source
Unknown: when they're up against Bitmain. Yeah. Tyler and I were talking about this a bunch too. It's like literally
Unknown: the worst thing that could happen is we just buy a bunch of their chips. I don't see the downside. Right. Right. Because they might think the counter argument here is, well, that's you know, it might be advantageous to Bitmain if they learned more about how our chip worked. But the response to that is, one, their chips are already more efficient than yours, so you're already losing. And two Exactly.
We've said this before on the pod, these ASIC specialists,
these guys that design these things, they already freaking know everyone at each other's companies. It's the same circles. They went to school together. They studied together. They lived in China together. They know people that work at their competitors. They know exactly how it's made. I mean, it's not like a black box to them. Right. Yeah. A lot of revolving doors there too. Yeah. It's like, alright. Maybe we don't know exactly how your chips work, but your competitors definitely do. Like Mhmm. They definitely do. So you're not, like, protecting any IP here by like refusing to sell chips to, you know, open source builders. Yeah. And even if they like publish their blueprint for their ASIC chips today, who's got $10.20,
Unknown: dollars 30,000,000
laying around to take that and bring it to TSMC and get them printed? Yeah. It's just this hoarding
Unknown: of what you know out of fear that someone's gonna cheat you. But I just feel like the people that are capable of doing it, they already have if they were going to. Exactly. Do you guys know about the workshop Ryan's giving in Nairobi this week for open source edition of Bitcoin plus plus Yeah. He's giving So yeah, Ryan traveled out to Nairobi.
Unknown: BTC plus plus is going on out there.
The guys from our friends from Gridless are out there with him. So I think that I'm I'm I'm getting FOMO about that one because it just sounds like it's gonna be amazing. Ryan is giving a couple of talks.
Got links to him somewhere, but short of pulling up those links at a really high level, he's giving, like,
a very broad overview of what the two fifty six foundation does and the mission and the purpose of the foundation. So kinda like what we were talking about earlier, you know, why is open source Bitcoin mining important?
What are the inherent risks of centralization
across pools, centralization of hardware,
centralization
of firmware,
even the mining rewards going to just a handful of custodians.
So there's centralized pitfalls all over the industry. Open source
breaks all of them up. So there is a lot of importance there. So he'll be giving a talk on that at like a high level, which I think would be appropriate for like anybody who's remotely interested in Bitcoin. But then he's gonna be doing a second talk that
really drills down into the technical
workings of the Mugena firmware that Ryan has been developing.
Amazing.
And maintaining.
And
that's gonna be more of a higher
high degree of technical in-depth lecturing.
So I think there's gonna be
a lot of people in the audience that'll be into that one as well. Can't wait to hear how that goes. He's bringing something for everybody.
Unknown: This is an important thing to get out there because we
were talking about earlier, right? There's a lot of sort of Bitcoin core,
node, wallet developers.
Right? And they're very much in the software realm. And I think sometimes they're like, oh, well, I don't do hardware. But firmware,
it's just software. It's just software
that controls hardware. Like, software developers would do will do great at it. Right? And I think if we can kind of just sort of break down, like, how Magena works I mean, it's a software project. Right? It it Totally.
You know, there's very little in there that depends on hardware specifically,
and we've got a pretty good handle on that part. You know, the rest is is software engineering that are that are just general concepts that people who've been working in software for a long time, I think, can be very good at. So to the extent that we can get more of the traditional Bitcoin software developers at least fired up on Mugena and open source firmware,
I think this could could really be an impactful project that can provide a lot of value
and a lot of decentralization
for Bitcoin mining. Yeah. It's He
Unknown: Go ahead, Iko. I was just gonna say he's he's, you know, slowly
building up that community of support and momentum.
He's been doing these dev calls on Mondays.
Unknown: Yes. That's what I was gonna say. It was a it was a great one this past Monday. Shout out to Jair and
Brett who've been joining,
Average Gary,
Dylan and I,
among others. Recently, the topic was about, you know, for example, the way Dylan explained something to me is like, this is so cool. I mean, this is the opportunity to be a part of the development of an early stage open source firmware project. You request
a thousand watts instead of 2,000 watts. If you have multiple hash boards, how do you want the firmware to be able to make that request and throttle down? Does it
shut off one of two boards that are each a thousand watts? Does it put each board at 500 watts? Are the boards two different
types of boards with different chips on them? Does it optimize for
the best split between those two boards to get you the best efficiency? Does it optimize
Unknown: for the best split between those two boards to get you the highest outlet temperature? Like, these are all the things we have to decide that have been completely siloed and closed, and we don't know how it works in the closed source firmwares. Right? You didn't get an option. It just you had your hacky solution. If you if you could with an aftermarket firmware, you could dial back the wattage, but you didn't really control how it made that decision. And as a nondev, I just love joining the calls and being able to to listen in to these kind of opportunities to decide how we architect this firmware. Right. It is it is a big project to think about how to architect some software like Mugena because we don't wanna necessarily prescribe how you have to do something like that. Like, how do you wanna split up the the power amongst the hash boards? Because it it's really dependent on the use case. Mhmm. It's really dependent upon the hardware that you wanna attach to it, what the best way to do this is. So we wanna provide, you know, optionality for people who are building these systems and people who are running these systems to do it how they want. Obviously, you don't wanna have to program it from scratch, but you need to have this framework, this like kernel of mining that that can do all these things and is modular
enough so that you can you can add it and make it do what you want. That's where the where the real value comes in for individual miners is like, all right, you you think you can do it better? Like, here's the tools, here's the here's the system that you can modify and try it out and prove out that you're doing it the best way. Exactly. So that's yeah. The the architecture of Mugena is
very important, and I'm very excited to see that Ryan is taking this seriously
and,
you know, really trying to
Unknown: make a modular system that people can do this with relatively easily. And he was saying recently too, I thought I saw him say something about possibly having
Moojina ready to flash onto the s 19
by the end of the month. Oh. Nice.
Right? Because I Scott, I know you've done it, but it's like it's not, for lack of better term, it's not very straightforward.
Unknown: Is that accurate? Yeah. Yeah. I just like I did a gnarly vibe coded hack. Right? You know, they it's a it is a weird place to be in as a developer to be like, I don't actually understand all of why this is working, but,
it is working, but it's such a proof of concept.
Right? You know, what we need is, is people to be building ready to go images for these different machines so that you can just slap it on there and it'll work. But then, of course, it's all also open source. So if you wanna change something about it, you can do that. But, yeah, that we we've you know, I I kinda was just, like, hyping that I had got it working and several people came out of the woodwork and they're like, oh my gosh. I wanna try this. Right? So they took my super hacky vibe coded thing and they super hacky vibe coded it onto their machines and got it working. But it's like, we just saw a lot of interest in doing this, like right out the gate. So I think Yeah. You struck a nerve. I think people were like, man, this is a possibility.
Which is really cool for me to see because, you know, these control boards, they're just Linux systems. They just run applications,
and, like, the sky's the limit on what you can do. So the the more we can get this out there,
and people can start playing with it, we're gonna see some amazing,
Unknown: you know, hacks and production ready tweaks to it. So this is very exciting. Yeah. That's worth reiterating because I was explaining the Libre board to someone in Oslo and it's really just a computer that runs this software that we refer to as mining firmware that tells the hash boards how to run. Anything could be a control board in that sense, your laptop, your phone, a Raspberry Pi. I mean, what what really defines
the
control board term is just the the expected
input and output IO on the actual hardware. What a typical miner might want to have to connect to. But it doesn't have to be that. Yeah. I mean, we're talking academically,
Unknown: it it's not like what's running on the miner is not firmware.
You're running an application. And I know that I think Mugena has been the first mining application
where people can really wrap their head around the fact that, yeah, this can run on your, like your MacBook, like just as a regular application. You can run it on your MacBook. You can connect your mind over your USB and just do it. Right? It really demystifies it, I think. And I know that Ryan's been doing a lot and a lot of others have been doing developing for Regina just, you know, from their computer, right? It's like modify the app, run on your computer, the miner's connected. Like it really, you don't have to flash it to something, right? You just run it. Like these are just applications.
Unknown: It's it's kinda cool. Yeah. The the takeaway for me there is like to watch all these heat punks, for example, thinking about building hot tub heating systems like we have that that early awesome system from Snorkel and Hashrate House, and they're talking about, hey. I need a control board that can talk to the the hot tub pump microcontroller.
And this is where understanding how what Mugena is and what LibreBoard is. The actual answer to that is you don't need two controllers. Run Mugena on the hot tub controller. And if you can't, then design the hot tub controller software to run on the LibreBoard. Yep. Yes. Yes. In other products, they're not called control boards per se. That's just become a colloquial term in Bitcoin mining, I think. But most systems, your refrigerator, whatever, they all have microcontrollers.
Unknown: That's what a miner needs as well. Right. Yeah. And these days, a lot of those those systems are running embedded Linux. Right? Yeah. So, like, the firmware is kinda like, in this case, is the OS.
Right? It's what boots Linux
on these embedded systems. But then, you know, assuming it's not locked down like a lot of them are, but you can just you can run whatever you on there you want on there. They're resource constrained systems, but, know, we're we're making huge advancements. I mean, right, to think you have an embedded system that has, like, a gigabyte of RAM is insane, and that's definitely the case now. Yeah. Well, definitely check out the forum to keep up to date on our calendar there for future dev calls on Mugena or potentially dev calls that may come about at a later time for other projects as well because it's a great way to actually sit down with the lead engineers, ask questions, talk about your PRs, your issues that you arise,
everything, and really get to architect this stuff together, which is so fun. It's so exciting, man. Getting in there and figuring out how these things work and adding new stuff. And especially with AI, man, you can you can try stuff out so quickly. Yeah. I got Wi Fi working on my CamLogic control board in my s 19 j pro. It's just like Yeah. That was sick. Like, if you you just make a few small changes and now you have just a regular USB port, you can connect whatever you want to it. Shall I read through some hashers? Yeah, let's hear them. Yeah. We've consistently had so I'm on dash. 256f.org,
Unknown: the amazing hash dash built
generously by d plus plus We've had 160
plus terahash for quite some time. Yeah. Like, since the last telehash, I think. That's right. I don't think it's really dipped below this number for quite some time now. Thanks to Tesserae who's got a solid 60 plus terahash on that leaderboard there in number number one spot. We've got Exergy, Tesori,
Fax seven seven seven, handful of small nerd axes and big bit axes from Bitcoin Park, Sarkasahash,
Eco Scott, hardestblocks.org,
UnknownAdi.
If you don't know Adi because he's unknown,
Unknown: he's doing some cool stuff with Audi. Shout out to Audi, man. That dude is just crushing it. I love how he just dives into these things. Yeah. What's he working on now? Getting Doom on the Brains Mini Minor because it's got that big touch screen. Yeah. This one is MinorBBM101
Unknown: Doom. And then, what was he working on? Well, he's working with Pizandy on the modified
Canin Avalon Nano three s hash board system for the three d printer miner slash three d print filament dryer.
And then he was working on, like, a PCIe Gen four,
almost like a GPU
card style miner that could slot into a motherboard of a desktop computer. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. There was that that
Unknown: competition
a while back from
was it PlebLab in Atlanta?
Yeah. And I think he won with the hardware category with his PCIe
miner.
Unknown: Yes, that's right. Agent P. Check out last week's episode with Agent P to hear
solution for a decentralized pool protocol that actually doesn't use a share chain.
Unknown: Oh, 30 megahertz undervolt.
This is wild. That is a really,
really
underclocked. Mugena, 30 megahertz undervolt? Yeah. I mean, these things normally run at, like, 500
to 600 megahertz. So he's got it down real low, which So for the novices, undervolting
Unknown: is your way of increasing efficiency.
Unknown: Yes. Yes. So, like, if you need if you wanna underclock,
you need to turn down the clock rate. That's the megahertz part. But then if you wanna do it efficiently, you also need to, drop the voltage. So that'd be undervolting it. And the result is your hash rate obviously goes way down, but the efficiency
can
improve
quite a bit. So there's two knobs. There's two knobs.
And this is this is exciting because actually Peter Todd made a post about this the other day, but miners
are, like, a fundamental level, are really well suited to connecting to solar panels directly.
Like Yeah. They're both low voltage DC devices. But in order to make solar panels work properly, you need to match
the the power draw with what's being generated by the panels for any given amount of sunlight. If you try and draw too much from a panel under a given sunlight scenario,
you'll actually get, like, nothing out of it. You'll crash it, and it'll just go all the way down. So the trick here is to dynamically adjust
the hash rate, so either overclock it or underclock it to perfectly match what the panel the solar panel is generating. And we've had troubles doing this in the past. I know H and P has been working on this and a few others, k one. We need to we need to quickly adjust
the hash rate. So you need to be able to quickly under underclock it or overclock it, and you need to be able to do it over a wide range. And so both of those things have been hard to do. So there's definitely some r and d that needs to be done on that. But seeing that he can get it, that agent p can get it so significantly
Unknown: underclocked is a really good sign. Yeah. And the importance here of solving for that optimization is the current hacky solution right now, I mean, the best you can do with how responsive these machines are is that you need to make sure you don't over ask for power from the panels that doesn't exist so the miners shut off. So instead, you kinda have this, like, safety zone, this buffer.
Unknown: And what it means is you're not optimally using all of the available solar power. Some is going to be wasted. Yeah. I mean, there there's a couple different scenarios here. One is which you got a shit ton of solar panels and you're just sort of using the excess of which there will be, you know, at peak sunlight periods every day. But the other sort of very exciting scenario is
one in which you are making a miner that is going to use all of the power generated by a solar panel. Like, they're very closely matched. And so then when, you know, a cloud goes by and it the sun goes down or at night, like, you just slowly ramp down the miner to match the power output from the panel. Exactly.
Yeah. That's wicked cool. Yeah. It's cool. It's cool. I think there's there's some really neat stuff that that could be here. I it was cool that Peter Tau just was, like, seemingly came up with this idea out the blue on his own and just posted the whole thing. I'm like, yes. Oh, man.
We've been trying to figure out how to do this for a long time, but what we need is is,
some of the the research that Agent P is doing. And then, of course, the hardware that's designed to do that, you know, because this is a direct DC type scenario. Yeah. I think eventually what would be sweet is just the the hash boards, like, on the backside of the solar panel. The the miner is the solar panel.
Yes. Yes. That sounds like a big thermal problem, but in that sense, like, the device, the panel just decides, okay. Do I send this power to the building? Do I send this power back to the grid? Do I send this power to the Bitcoin network? What do I do? Yeah. I mean, the BitX was originally that was the that was the idea behind it was it was gonna be mounted to the back of a solar panel, and it was, not gonna be connected to the grid. Right? That's why I added Wi Fi is because it's gonna be totally wireless. You can imagine having this solar panel, and you just put it outside, and it just connects to the network and starts mining whenever the sun comes up. It was that's why it was called Dayminer before it was called Bitax. Interesting. Dang. Mine during the day. Right? You can imagine if you have these things, you just you just can go litter them out in your lawn or up on your roof or whatever, and they just completely wireless mining. As soon as the sun comes up, they just start mining as much as possible, and then a bird sits on the panel and
Unknown: drop down to whatever you know, it just dynamically adjusts to whatever the panel is outputting. You just inspired me to go look at our solar production here at the space. We generated 115
kilowatt hours yesterday. Holy smokes. Nice. Gotta be mining more. Yeah. Four fourteen kw peak for, like, three hours straight, we're generating 14 kW. Did you guys use all of that to mine or what? That's interesting because it seems like this has been new learning for me. The inverter doesn't tell you in real time how much the building's using and how much excess is being generated
and how much it's, like, sending back to the grid. So you can kind of eyeball it by estimating the constant load from your refrigerator,
estimate the load on your just look at the current voltage on the the compressor for the air conditioning unit, but you don't know in real time. Dylan had a cool solution for this. He bought this, like, CT clamp kit,
and he clamped these meters onto the wires behind his breaker panel. So he opened up the breaker panel, and they just are sensors that feed that data to Home Assistant. So you do know in real time how much the whole property is drawing and then you can map that delta to the miner. I see. What we really need, I mean, is all that
modification
and tunability
of Mugena and the hash board
to talk directly to the inverter system on the panels because that is what's also talking if you're connected to the utility as well or if you're not. Like, that's what's
telling the miner you have this much excess. Man, when open source inverter firmware? Yeah, that's a good question. I'm sure it might exist. Someone's probably hacked some of them. When would someone want to sell back to the grid instead of mine Bitcoin?
Unknown: Because they get a fraction of what they paid for the electricity. It depends on the utility.
Unknown: They try to make it as complicated as possible. I spent a lot of time researching this here in Colorado on Excel. They charge you 15¢ to buy it, but then they will give you 15¢
in credit to your utility account if you send it back.
Where have we seen this before? But yeah, it is applied to bank of credits. You can only apply to proceeding months and at the end of the year, any leftover credits get paid out to you at like 1¢. So their credit's locked in the utility account at one to one value. But if there's ever any excess,
they pay you out at like a tenth of the or a fifteenth of the value. Using that power excess power to mine Bitcoin just seems like such a no brainer. I would think it'd be easier for the grid too.
Unknown: I'm just wondering if that proposition would solve a lot of problems for them. If you went to the grid and said, hey. Do you hate managing tens of thousands of homes sending tiny amounts of power back to you? About we just stop doing that? I I heard the craziest story. I was talking to someone, I think it was in Prague, and they're somewhere in Europe. And the the amount that the utility will pay you for that excess power that you send back to the grid is, like, dynamically adjusts all the time, and sometimes it goes negative. It blew my mind. Like, meaning they
charge you to send power back to them. So this guy literally has space heaters in a barn in his yard. Insane.
Unknown: It's insane. Like, what the fuck is going on here? Like, the dude just just is heating up his barn just for no good reason. Like, just so that he doesn't have to pay because he's generating excess power. If they're gonna have such convoluted pricing structures like that, they simply must. It's so insane to me that not all of them have public APIs. Like, I was looking into that. I cannot get an API to our utility account to link it to our minor logic, to our solar logic, to our inverter, to these automations
because it's like they're trying to fuck you. And I'm trying to intelligently
limit that Yeah. But they won't give you their side of the information that you need to solve this equation. Right? So you're just left guessing. And I guess the answer is to not connect to the grid, I mean, that's not the name of the game for most people. So it's frustrating. There was a guy on Twitter, I don't know, maybe
Unknown: one or two years ago, Satoshi Onanamoto.
And he do you remember this, Scott? No. He had pulled in he had gotten an API from
his utility company. Was like Yeah. It does exist. It's rare though. Yeah. But he it was cool because he could monitor in real time pricing information
and then make an intelligent decision about whether he should mine or not. I know the situation's a little bit different than creating excess energy, but still,
Unknown: there is some info out there. There was a cool paper that was published a few years ago. Think it was it was from Square. So it was long enough ago that they were the block was called Square.
And I I wanted it was someone else, maybe like Arc Invest. And it was just a paper documenting this exact paradigm of, like, you know, there's gonna be you wanna have a controller,
and there's gonna be a time in which it makes sense to either charge your batteries or to mine Bitcoin or to sell it back to the grid. And you can just make that decision in real time and, you know, do whatever makes the most sense. Mhmm. I mean, it seems like such an obvious idea, but I think there's probably so many different APIs from different power companies around the world, and then miners aren't really set up to sort of just dynamically mine, ramp up and down like that.
Yet. Yet. Yet. I think this this just you know, the the mining OS of the future will will just, you know, figure that out. Right? Because over time, you could figure out, you know, what your your normal household power usage is,
and you could just figure out, like, should I be charging my batteries right now? Do I know A 100%. I'm not gonna need that? Like, I have enough or they're fully charged? Like, what do I do at any given time? I think the, the Tesla Powerwalls do have something like that. Like, they can decide, you know, because they have the solar panels too. Right? They can decide, you know, should I be charging my car? Should I be charging my Powerwall? Or should I The car can even charge the house. Yeah. Right. So they have this crazy dynamic system that can go a lot of different ways. I think in like Texas,
they can actually like sell into the open power market. Yeah. There's something similar too with Generac
Unknown: generators,
propane generators,
or sorry, natural gas generators in Texas because ERCOT, it's its own grid. They can determine, they have an API, they talk to the grid when electric pricing is high because the grid is stressed, your home can just switch over to natural gas based generator
Unknown: electricity. It's amazing. It is amazing. That's really cool. That's yeah. I mean, we need that software. We need it to not be locked into these proprietary ecosystems so that all sorts of people can benefit from it, all sorts of different setups. I seem to remember there was some power event in Texas and people were like, oh yeah, discharge my car, sell it to the grid. Let's
go. I don't need that. It
Unknown: is doable now. It's just a little hacky. That's how we're doing it here at my office.
The heated floor miner has also got a dry cooler outside, so we're just dumping heat when there's excess solar. And we don't have much resolution on it. It's just like, okay. Based on what we know the refrigerators
and the lights and the air conditioning uses, we estimate how much extra might be available. And if there's four kilowatts plus available, then we just turn on the four kilowatt m 64.
But doing just that simple logic has I'm looking at it here. We've made a 100,000 sats this month already. $67.
So and that's, you know, sats in our wallet, not credits in our utility. Yeah. We gotta get we gotta get Mugena control for those Wetsminer hydro. That'll be a huge unlock. Yeah. I talked to I I emailed David Urlacher, who's a firmware engineer at Luxor, and I said, yo. I saw you guys announced in Vegas you're doing LuxOS on Watsminers.
And he said the because they're they're doing the secure boot. Right? They have to crack secure boot or maybe if they're partnered with WhatsMiner now, there was some collaboration.
Maybe it's a little bit more polished than that, but
the hard part being Secure Boot. He mentioned though that the m 64 was not on the road. M 64, m 74, and it's like, dang, I guess. This is the problem with closed source. It's like, I get it. You're a business. You're adding features. You warrant a dev fee for your efforts. But there's always edge cases of people that just wanna do something else, and it sucks being siloed off. Yeah. Right. And it's the chicken and the egg problem. It's like,
Unknown: they're like, Oh, there isn't a market for this. We're not going to dedicate our resources to it. And then the potential market is like, Well, there's no firmware to do it, so we're not going to, you're not going to do it. And that's
tough to break out of, hopefully.
Unknown: Maybe we could learn something from how they implement LuxOS on other Watts miners for the hacking of the specific m 64. Is that possible you think, Scott? Maybe. We'll see. Maybe. We'll see. Alright. Let me finish reading through some more hashers here. D plus plus friend of the show. Shout out to d. Myself, Backwater Mining Collective, Dylan, Satoki,
Woodminer, Tubaloo, p Buttweiler, Pazandy,
Schnitzel,
Johnny nine, and click here in case of mind block. Not a lot of change in the difficulty leaderboard. I don't think we've seen this change since the telehash. So eight of the Yeah. I think that stayed the same. Yeah. And on that What's Minor note, I just wanted to add, I think I anticipate
Unknown: we'll see something come out of this Nairobi conference that Ryan is at because the guys at Gridless
have a lot of what'sminers and one of their employees is working on that.
Bitshoka. Bitshoka.
Yeah, Bitshoka.
Shoka. Yes.
Unknown: Yeah. It means axe in Swahili, apparently. Shoka. Yeah. With Watsminer chip on it. Yes. Right?
Unknown: Very exciting. They've got one with the Bitmain chip, but then they've got this other one with the Watsminer chip that they're developing. So I anticipate,
I don't know for sure or not, but I anticipate Ryan's gonna get to spend some good quality time with the guy that's working on that. Yeah, know shout out to Kurt. Kurt, yeah. And I know that Ryan has been eager
to to get something working with Mugena and WhatsMiner.
He's even asked me about picking up one of those WhatsMiners I have in the storage unit. So There we go. Nice. Yeah. Hopefully, something soon. It would be great because doesn't seem like anyone else has really cracked that egg. No. It's kind of funny. You
Unknown: know, Bitmain also has Secure Boot, but they in typical Bitmain fashion, I guess, they just implemented it really poorly so it's easy enough to exploit. I wonder if
if What's Miner has done a more secure implementation of Secure Boot, making our lives harder. Probably.
Unknown: We'll see. You can always make a new control board. That's right. Yep. Well, cool. Do you guys got anything else, or should we wrap it up there? I think let's wrap. Let's try to get NG on the pod soon among other guests. It was fun having agent p on last week. So if you'd like to be a guest on the pod, just hit us up. Tell us what you're working on, what you wanna talk about. I'd love to. Yeah. Alright. Cool. Well, thanks you guys, and we'll see you next week. See you. Later.